it's being called an attack on press
freedom Australian police have raided
the offices of the country's national
broadcaster they've accused ABC of
publishing classified material is really
serious and we take it very very
seriously and you know it feels
uncomfortable because this is a personal
comment it's not the Australia I know
for example I've been a reporter in this
country for a long long time and it's
not what we expect the Raiders to do
with a 20-17 report on allegations of
abuse by Australian special forces in
Afghanistan a senior editor live tweeted
the police's actions posting a
photograph of their warrant it's based
on a century-old law but gives the
police modern powers to access emails
and other electronic files the drama
unfolded as Australia's new prime
minister was on the other side of the
world he met the Queen in London
yesterday and was taking part in D Day
commemorations today the action against
ABC has raised fears about a harsh
climate for the media under his
government we respect the independence
of the Fourth Estate but at the same
time this is an ongoing investigation it
would be inappropriate for me to comment
this newspaper journalist had her house
raided as well this week in what police
say was an unrelated case we live in a
democracy democracies rely upon freedom
of the press Anika Schmitt Hirst is a
serious professional journalists who has
my respect is quite frankly I think
outrageous that seven officers spent
seven and a half hours in her home both
raids are linked to the alleged use of
classified information by journalists
whether justified or not it's sure to
send a chill through other Australian
newsrooms Deborah Haynes Sky News